good morning and welcome to you all I'm
Jim valentini the Dean of Columbia
College and vice president for
undergraduate education at Columbia it's
my pleasure to open this forum symposium
workshop it's all of those today the
power of community engagement impact
innovation and the individual this is a
very important effort in which the three
key words and the title are indeed the
operative words it is taking individuals
college and School of Engineering and
Applied Sciences students and training
them to be innovators to be effective at
having a genuine impact on the
communities in which they live the
communities that surround them and the
world at large today we're going to have
panels which include creating a
sustainable community ensuring access to
healthy food another advocating for a
just community creating new pathways to
justice and one creating a global
community social media and social change
this forum is the culminating event of
the 2011 Kenneth Cole community
engagement program which is a new
initiative of columbia college and the
School of Engineering and Applied
Sciences that seeks to develop skills
for effective social change in motivated
and socially conscious Columbia
undergraduates and it was to give them
an opportunity to refine those skills
and capitalize on their motivation
through actual practice in summer
experiences in the community students
selected for this program who are named
Kenneth Cole fellows spend two semesters
on campus studying urban issues and
learning about community engagement
collaboration leadership and problem
solving and then embarked on a summer
long internship at
a local community organization at which
they can use the skills that they have
developed in the classroom and refine
those skills in actual practice
approximately a dozen sophomores and
juniors undergraduates are selected for
this program each year today there will
be presentations by the 2011 kevin cole
fellows who spent the summer this past
summer 2011 working for 3 not-for-profit
organizations in New York their summer
projects are focused on initiatives that
address local problems encourage social
action strengthen communities and
promote social change during the summer
of two thousand eleven Columbia students
work for the community league of the
heights known by the acronym cloth legal
information for families today lift and
the mary mitchell family and youth
center students working for cloths
surveyed the community about what
services were needed at a new community
center in washington heights those that
lift also surveyed community members
about how to better provide legal
information and education to children
and families in the community those at
the mary mitchell family and youth
center created a business plan for a new
program to distribute affordable fresh
fruit and vegetables in the South Bronx
these are important efforts on the part
of the students and an important
collaboration with the community they
are also an important collaboration with
our partner today Kenneth Cole who I
have the honor of introducing to you
Kenneth is chairman and chief creative
officer of Kenneth Cole productions
which as probably all of you know
designs sources and markets apparel
footwear handbags and accessories the
kenneth cole foundation which he founded
promotes encourages and inspires
positive and meaningful social change by
raising awareness about important social
issues motivating what Kenneth calls
change agents and we agree with that
appellation and supporting like-minded
organizations Kenneth wanted to create
this program at Columbia to teach
students
who our future community leaders how to
reach for social change within both
their local communities and the world at
large Kenneth has said that he hoped
quote to empower and further inspire
Columbia's talented student body with
necessary tools to be able to make
meaningful and sustainable differences
in their respective communities to
become effective social entrepreneurs
and the next generation of change agents
we are happy to work with him on this
important and significant effort and we
appreciate his support for that Kenneth
and Columbia are proud to be partners in
this initiative we agree with him when
he said I have always believed that our
universities need to recognize their
interdependence with our communities and
that the best way to address their
individual needs and to provide for
their collective futures is through
collaborative programs like this today
we're going to hear about the results of
collaborative programs like this and
we're going to begin that with some
remarks from mr. Cole himself Kenneth I
am very happy to introduce Kenneth Cole
thank you very much Dean valentini um I
just prepared a few short remarks and
some of which the Dean actually alluded
to but I'm thrilled actually to be
partnering with Columbia in this program
at this really important point in time
and we're living in a very different
world right now and one I hope that you
can appreciate its differences as as we
do there is little today that is the way
it was a year two years ago even a year
ago we all know that there is no longer
to begin with proprietary access to
knowledge one no longer has to go to the
finest universities to have access to
the greatest minds and the most
inspiring thinkers all information today
is available to anyone anywhere at any
time so what we seek today is as we know
what the best curators of it all the
ability to bring it together bring
together community of like-minded
individuals who inspire each other
that's what cumbia does best and and
that's at programs like this or example
of such the internet of material so no
has made the world very small our heads
are spinning just to keep up with all
the knowledge all the news that is now
available in real time by animal sources
that unfathomable speeds change is
happening by the second two years ago no
one could have anticipated the
technology that exists today in the
proverbial bridges it has helped to
build in the social structural barriers
it has helped bring down
used to be the empowered minority
privileged members of the media spoke on
behalf of the empowered unempowered
majority but now with the evolution of
new media the new and ever-changing
world social media everyone as a voice
all can and are heard and all can and do
find audiences the recently empowered
individual today has the ability to
mobilize entire communities was talking
to Dean and a more earlier about how the
natural instinct of engineering students
today too they often come in idealistic
and look to want to change the world and
then they look and realize at a certain
point in the process that they they look
towards Wall Street as a vehicle to help
pay their bills and and to help them
facilitate such and and I'd suggested
that maybe there are two alternatives
today they can either work on Wall
Streeter they can occupy wall street we
watched a no longer silent majority in
Cairo mobilized overnight and overthrow
that which restrained them through
social media a regime then fell in Libya
without anyone really seeing it coming
and now we're watching occupiers stand
up to the status quo in overwhelming
numbers in cities around the world and
not even they seem to know where they're
going tomorrow or even today which is
what's so estate
we all know that there is an immense
amount of injustice and inequality and
that our communities around the world of
fragile and Industry and in disrepair
make it more important than ever for
business and communities to take down
their walls recognize that independence
while at the same time find the creative
inappropriate ways to connect their
greater communities and to the same
degree universities of communities need
to better recognize their
interdependence as the involuntary just
said and and that each other is apt to
adequately promote ensure their present
and future well-being we need to gay
engage and be engaged by the limited
resources while having meaningful and
sustainable impact on the greatest
number of individuals to build
communities we hire builders of
buildings to build communities requires
community builders which begins with
empowering engaging and inspiring the
most qualified amongst us there is a
notion that you can contribute to our
community or give back after you had the
means community engagement is as viable
as any path to those means and I think
we're learning that if one can make it
part of the journey it will assuredly be
as if not more rewarding as any both
spiritually as well as financially I
real I realized early on that my
business as fulfilling as it was could
in fact have been so much more
meaningful and I realized the power of
addressing not just what our customers
stood in but what they stood for not
just what they wear but that they be
aware could provide a much more
meaningful and substantive platform as
the world changes before our eyes I
believe the greatest service we can
provide for our communities to assist in
identifying inspiring and empowering our
future leaders and the necessary with
the necessary
tools to anticipate our collective needs
and to create an innovative and
meaningful impact the students are in an
extraordinary place to be those builders
of communities and those agents of
important change Colombia has a long
history of community in public service
and I hope this program can help evolve
it to another level by actively
developing and empowering our next
generation of leaders and change agents
and closing up just share with your
favorite story of mine you may have
heard this or a version of it it's a
it's a story of a young college student
who's driving his car on the upper west
side of manhattan late one night and
gets a call from a parent who says that
they just heard on the radio that there
was a lunatic on a road that they know
that they are often on driving in the
wrong direction after careful pause and
not wanting to unnecessarily alarm the
parent the student responded it's worse
than that there were hundreds of them
the lesson being even if you feel you're
going against traffic that doesn't
necessarily mean you're going in the
wrong direction thank you for your
support today and I'm very excited about
all that we have in store for us today
and I thank our friends for making that
happen to bringing that to us